porque no se han despertado esta mañana
con unas nuevas declaraciones de su
vecino ruso el ministro de asuntos
exteriores sérguei lávrov ha insistido
en que rusia no tiene ninguna intención
de iniciar una guerra con ucrania pero
también ha advertido de que moscú va a
seguir defendiendo sus intereses desde
aquí desde que el propio presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski ha pedido a
los países occidentales que no añadan
más pánico a la situación el gobierno
ucraniano sabe que al otro lado de la
frontera hay en torno a 100 mil soldados
rusos pero insiste en que no es la
primera vez ni siquiera en los últimos
meses que están los ucranianos bajo esta
presión de hecho insisten en que
precisamente uno de los peligros es que
ante esta escalada de tensión se
produzca algún tipo de provocación por
parte de rusia